let's uh let's let's let's circle back
we're going to circle back to this uh
political story we have this from the
daily mail
you guys want to talk about civil war
let's talk about civil war louisiana
advances bill classifying abortion as
homicide republican representative
behind the bill says the state cannot
wait on the supreme court the move on
wednesday came two days after the leaked
draft about roe v wade louisiana state
rep danny mccormick a republican
introduced the abolition of abortion act
in march
the legislation approved in a 7-2
committee vote now moves to the state's
full house
the louisiana bill is one of the raft of
proposals by lawmakers in conservative
states such restrictions could go
further than the so-called trigger laws
bans uh and other regulations that will
take effect in some 26 states should row
be overturned
so let's talk about this means if
abortion is homicide
that means a lot in terms of what
happens to abortion providers can i ask
you something is there a difference
between the legal classification of
homicide in the legal classification of
murder
if you're to write a law that says x is
homicide does that mean i'm open to
being considered murder but not
necessarily considered murder in every
case or is it a different technology
yeah homicide means a human killed a
human yeah yeah exactly exactly but
they're so so homicide could be
involuntary manslaughter it could be
first-degree murder or second-degree
murder i'm curious if this is specified
in any way
did they mention the degree they're
calling it they're saying it's homicide
which means they're they're granting
life rights to the future yes
yeah which means what are they part of
the consensus i asked this before the
show it's a silly question but like are
they gonna classify these these now
humans as part of the census when
they're taking a census come on i mean
they're not human they're not people yet
well they're not giraffes man they're
not people though they're just they're
developing fetus humans they're not
people until they get a birth
certificate legally no uh that would
that that's the logic they used to keep
slaves in well that's the law that's the
law right now if you want to change the
law and say that they're people and
that's what birth certificate on
conception no no no no the law isn't
that you you gain personhood with a
birth certificate
there's there's no law that says there's
no i mean there's no person until
there's a a personality
no that's not true or until that's
legally called no personality
let's look up what a person is yeah look
actually that's a good idea let's define
let's get some i mean it's a
philosophical distinction right but i
would actually make the argument that
the distinction between you know so so i
guess you can make an argument there
that there are persons who aren't human
right but every human is a person you
can't not grant rights to a living human
being a person is
a the body of a human being
that that's been the worst civil rights
violations in our country's history is
when we've tried to define personhood
and who is or who is not worthy enough
to be a person so this is this is where
i think the uh the abortion issue is
very much um our second civil war
catalyst they they had actually argued
in in pre-civil war that slaves didn't
have personhood that they didn't have
the same rights the constitution didn't
apply to them they weren't they they had
no personhood you cannot allow someone
to arbitrarily decide when a human being
is a person or women weren't even
granted the same rights just a couple
decades before roe was was passed yeah
well the argument i would make and part
of why i'm saying that there are the
persons who aren't human is like so for
example it is a little tricky
definite it's a little tricky definition
wise and i appreciate you asking the
question because my my first thought was
well maybe it's a false distinction but
also i know that like as catholics we
will use the the phrase person to
sometimes apply to the the members of
the trinity but that said when you're
talking about human beings specifically
and people try to create this
distinction between a human and a person
to me that sort of smacks of the
arbitrary distinction between gender and
sex i think it's just a false
distinction created so that you can do
depraved things you have right now
ian what you're saying is these human
beings are not people because we haven't
written the paperwork for them basically
yeah legally so but that but that's not
there's seven definitions of the word
person which is annoying but i'll pick
the sixth one because i think that's the
one this is from merriam-webster uh one
such as a human being a partnership or a
corporation that is recognized by law as
the subject of rights and duties so if
they change the law they become people i
guess by that definition the point is
there are you asking for paperwork to i
i reject outright that means you would
assert the right of the state to say
we've decided that ashley's not a person
for these arbitrators do they control
the census
that's that's a question for
the census for this governor for
personhood ian can i ask you something
because the birth certificate also
mentions the sex of the child are they
ambiguous with respect to their sex
prior to getting a birth certificate
because of that if you don't know what
the sex is yeah but there was tort law
for years
years and decades in this country that
recognize the unborn as persons as
regards to you know inheritance and
different things like that i mean we had
those laws when the 14th amendment was
ratified identifying tort laws
identifying the unborn as persons it can
also be because
i mean there are people who have also
been punished and you know for for
killing a woman who was pregnant and
yeah
as well you kill a baby in the womb but
you were about to explain i'm sorry i
cut you off i think he had asked you a
question
yeah so tort laws i mean there there are
laws that from what i understand and i'm
not you know a legal scholar but they
were laws that were like kind and not
laws but they were recognized for the
most part as like common law in the
united states but tort laws mostly refer
to property
um but there were tort laws in terms of
inheritance for the unborn in the united
states and what's interesting is the the
roe v wade decision they hinged it so
so strongly on the 14th amendment
and this you know right to privacy but
when the 14th amendment was ratified we
had these tort laws recognizing the
unborn as persons and you know having
rights to certain things so it was just
the mental gymnastics that was done in
this in the row decision in general just
as an abuse of discretion and
is insane and also when someone uses a
phrase like we found this in the
penumbra of the shadow
right you can say there's there could be
a chance that this is mental gymnastics
we saw this was like they said it was
enumerated rights followed by enumerated
problems right and they just first of
all there's not a right to privacy at
all there's no right to privacy in the
constitution you have some right to
privacy as it refers to the fourth
amendment and you know unwarranted
searches and seizures but you don't have
a right to privacy at all
well this is interesting what is this
interesting i mean
i have to so concerning the tort law you
mentioned is it so like if a woman is
pregnant and the father dies his inherit
say the mother and the father dies you
have to look it up because i don't want
to you know say the wrong thing but
there was
tort laws that recognized them i'm on
pubmed it says prenatal tort law and the
personhood of the unborn child a
separate legal existence but i can't
find i'm looking for doctor so i have a
docket from the supreme court
i just pulled it up i gotta look into it
a little bit more there's a fantastic
book too called the purpose of the
process
from 1850 to 1880 suggest that an unborn
child is a person within the meaning of
the 14th amendment to the u.s
constitution fascinating is so i have to
i have to look up what this is uh yeah i
want to read so and so many people think
that the argument is just oh you know i
think abortion's moral but no there was
serious abuse of discretion as it comes
to the way they decided this there was
populationist theory in the clerk's
memos
there was incredible influence from
populationists when they decided row it
is incredible when you look into it you
look from the clerk memos and everything
like that there were so many more things
that influence even ruth bader ginsburg
said it wasn't about women at all it
wasn't about women no abortion is not
about women it's about the abortion and
population i mean it's about the
abortion industry profiting off of
slaughtering unborn children and it's
about allowing men consequence-free
access to women's bodies like
consequence-free sexual activities
about keeping people that are poor from
having 50 kids yep it's sad but that's a
big part of it it's very sad i agree
because like human life is only valuable
if uh that person is born into a middle
class or upper class family yeah that's
very sad i mean that seems to be the
dominant moderator the challenge here
with not recognizing personhood for the
unborn is like a baby at eight and a
half months who's not yet been born
inside the womb next to a baby that is
eight and a half months from the point
of conception that was emergency
delivered by a c-section
that baby that's out of the womb can't
be touched but the baby that's still in
the womb of the exact same development
could be executed that is the way to go
i agree with you that is so weird you
had northam talking about not
resuscitating babies after they're born
no no resuscitating them and then having
a conversation about what to do next is
what he said and this is a question i
have look evil
i i can understand an argument
from the point of uh first trimester
nothing after nothing second or nothing
third in terms of abortion
but when you're talking about a viable
baby
that outside the womb of its own
independent life could not be harmed
under penalty of law and a baby exactly
the same but in the womb can be
something doesn't make sense it seems
like all these laws were written way
back in the day before modern technology
where you could do an ultrasound or like
see the baby struggling during an
abortion process trying to avoid the
forceps or whatever like uh before
before you knew the gender before it was
born because the 14th amendment
specifically says after they're born and
their no their standard was much
different so their standard was
quickening back then for abortion when
they did have abortions even back in the
day the standard was quickening which
was when you felt the baby and then when
they felt they found out that oh this
dude's actually alive a little sooner
than that they they amended it to hey
you know we should not be doing these as
soon as we know that they're there it
was as they thought that was conception
they didn't know that quickening was not
okay i'm pregnant this is when the baby
like it's just what is quickening
quickening is when you can feel the baby
moving
and so they had no idea that that was
not conception yeah exactly and so the
um the development of embryological
science has made it so much more clear
that it is a living person i mean i've
mentioned this before on the show 95
percent of biologists surveyed say life
begins at fertilization and so the
science is very much settled on this
issue i would say it makes it very clear
that it's a living organism whether or
not it's a person is a legal discussion
well what do you call a living human
is a living human not a person it
depends on what stage they're in uh if
it's the two days after conception it's
it's you could argue it's about to be a
human living and then it develops into a
human but it's not really a par i mean
the whole idea of a person is that it's
got a personality that it can
communicate that it's a person you know
i just i don't want to be on the wrong
side of that argument right because like
i said the worst civil rights violations
in our country's history in the world
have been when we've tried to decide who
is or who is not a person and i just
don't want to touch that i don't want to
be on the wrong side of history and
that's just well we're kind of creating
history right now yeah and i don't want
to be on the wrong side of it there was
there's no right or wrong here we just
got to do the best we can who cares well
ian so here's why i would push back on
that so
i think there are arguments that i could
make against your your definition of
personhood and in favor of the idea that
the unborn child is a person at all
stages but i believe that the burden of
proof is actually strongly on the the
one who says it isn't a person i think
you actually have to prove that because
for example if i'm going to detonate a
building
i need to know that there is no person
inside of it i can't say well there
might be we don't know it's a complex
philosophical discussion about whether
there's a person in there we're just
going to detonate it and if you know
someone dies someone dies i think we all
recognize you need to be 100 perfectly
clear that the activity you're partaking
in is not the killing of a person before
it's permissible at all
and that hasn't been proven and it
hasn't proven i mean because it is a
person but i don't even hear
left-wingers i don't even hear people in
favor of abortion try to advance an
argument that it's not a person they
just say it isn't or they say you
haven't proven it is a person it's just
like the burden of proof is on them
i mean without i don't want it to make
an emotional argument you had a baby you
had one inside of you so you understand
i guess it i would think that it starts
to develop a personality before it
leaves the female body at some point
whether or not you can interact with it
or not what does personality have to do
with someone whether that's someone's
personal personality is derived from the
person you know it's just these vague
terms no if there is a mute deaf child
we don't say they have no rights well so
like i would say it has a personality
like it might react different to
different stimuli in the womb so that
it's a type of personality you could
argue
this one doesn't
i mean when a person is unconscious
they're not displaying any traits of
personality no but they've already been
established it's a person that's
unconscious well let's say someone finds
like what if he's a naked person in a
hospital like a naked person in the
forest who's completely unconscious and
not responsive but has a heartbeat do
you just be like that's not a person i
can do whatever i want to it do they
have personhood if they have no no minds
if you find bro if you find an
unconscious woman and you do anything to
that woman you're going to prison for a
while so if you find a a body someone
like you said i don't think i don't know
vegetables probably an insensitive way
to talk about it but if someone's has
basically zero brain activity and
there's just a heartbeat and a body then
is it a person so yes
yes but also we will go to prison for
doing something to that body like
physically harming it and then even then
there isn't really a
perfect comparison there right because
in the case of an unborn child we know
that we are what 99 sure that they will
end up developing all of the cognitive
faculties that you're mentioning a
person in a coma lacking
yeah this is why i brought up birth
control at the beginning if that's also
like plan b i don't want to derail you
can i also mention something i just want
to say the person the definition of
personhood given by google is the least
helpful thing the least helpful
definition the quality or condition of
being an individual person
thank you so much
what about conjoined twins what about
conjoined twins are they not people the
other definition they give personhood or
personality is the status of being a
person oh thank you thank you so much
that's like yeah you can't this is the
first thing they teach you in an
etymology class you can't use the word
in the definition in or as if in a play
that's the definition of person come on
if you look at the supreme court docket
it says according to webster's
dictionary a child is a quote person not
yet of the age of majority so we are
using the word person in the definition
but the understanding is that someone
who is small is just a person who hasn't
reached for example the age of consent
this is why we understand that children
cannot consent to sex although this has
gone somewhat by the wayside in the age
of trans children but this is something
that they were mulling even back when
they were looking at abortion in the
first place i just think it's kind of
simple
can you kill a human unprovoked for no
reason
no only if they can only if you're in
the military
only if they can't make noise well
that's that i said no reason in the
military the military if you see a kid
walking well yeah you got everything
there's tons of reasons you're supposed
to have a reason you definitely can't
just go kill a kid you can they have the
power too and they have done it in the
past for sure and you look at the
massacre in vietnam you can physically
do a lot of things the point is under
the laws you so yeah but they'll get
protected look at the myelin massacre
all those guys got protected except for
the captain that initiated that massive
point is is there
did the children have personality is
there a reason yes war was the reason
can you walk up to a random person and
just end their life the answer is no is
a fetus a human being the answer is yes
therein lies the major conundrum the
left has to have to define a way when
life begins otherwise abortion if if you
were to if you were to operate
under the pretext of the 14th amendment
as per roe v wade the actual ruling
should be that you can't perform an
abortion because it would violate the
equal rights under the law of the of the
fetus which is a human being now they'll
try and use the argument that it says
persons born
but then you run to the conundrum which
i mentioned earlier a baby who is born
at eight months and a baby who is still
in the women eight months or identical
in every way one doesn't have rights
because of the layer of flesh around it
yeah that's modern technology is has is
forcing us to change the law no no
that's not matter technology there were
many circumstances in which a baby was
born at eight eight months and survived
eight months is viable without you know
i mean you might need
some medical intervention but let's say
eight night let's say let's say nine
months and one baby went a little bit
longer than nine months the law right
now is a baby at nine months fully
delivered and healthy and crying and a
baby that hasn't been delivered one can
legally be killed because they haven't
been given persons yeah
they are the same thing i know when i
got a 40 ultrasound it was this he
looked just the same when he came out
and he'd go in the same little position
i'm like you're the same little kid that
i saw oh gosh i just saw a picture of
somebody on twitter's show who was it oh
yes it is the case that in 1973 our
prenatal science was not as developed as
it is today we didn't know enough but
that's no excuse it's horrifically
irresponsible to say well we don't know
a whole lot about the circumstances in
the womb so we're just gonna err on the
side of go ahead and kill it well and
even then you know they said it should
be rare right and that was a big thing
even joe biden was saying it should be
rare and we've gone so far that not only
is it legal and acceptable but they're
shouting their abortions it's constant
it's they make it like it's removing a
wart and it's a simple easy procedure
that has no consequences and i just want
to mention one thing i know i'm sort of
talking about the science here i think
it's straightforward i think it's common
sense um that it is a person the entire
time it is a human being because that's
the only reason anyone wants to kill it
you wouldn't be killing it if it wasn't
a human person who you would be
responsible for i just don't want to
complete the word person with human at
this point because of their legal
definitions
yeah what would happen if you took a
newborn puppy and just put it outside
and walked away
not much
cassandra would come kill you cassandra
no i mean yeah i'm not sure what the uh
animal protection laws are but i assume
you would get in trouble for something
like that aren't there laws on the books
that prevent you from abusing animals or
neglecting i think you can have puppies
outside well yeah i mean if you leave a
dog outside right that's an animal but i
think tim is saying if a dog died
through negligence is that
if you take a newborn puppy and put it
in your backyard just walk away oh like
a newborn puppy that needs to be with
its mother i didn't say anything i said
what would happen if you did it i don't
know nobody would get nobody would care
mm-hmm like
you if you took a baby and walked
outside put it in the grass and watched
what's going on
even helplessness they are helpless for
so long my kid has no idea what he's
doing like he rolls over on his stomach
and he starts crying he's like i don't
know thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you